Вже сім років, як Росія анексувала Крим.
Щоб повернути півострів, Київ започатковує Кримську платформу.
Вона має розпочати свою роботу напередодні 30-річчя Незалежності України.
Західні експерти оцінюють це загалом позитивно,
але лунають і доволі скептичні оцінки щодо ініціативи Зеленського.
Сюзан Стюарт з берлінського Фонду "Наука і політика" у своїй статті
під назвою "Кримська платформа як ризик для порядку денного українських реформ"
вважає, що Кримська платформа забере багато уваги і сил, які терміново необхідні для вирішення інших проблем.
Нині Україна найбільше потребує успішних реформ у багатьох сферах.
Вона вже багато зробила, але багато ще попереду.
Особливо коли йдеться про судову реформу і боротьбу з корупцією.
І я щиро вважаю, що це так само важливо, як і захист від Росії.
Тож, якщо Україні вдасться успішно реформуватися і справді змінити нинішню управлінську систему,
тоді буде більше надійних гарантій проти подальшого проникнення з боку Росії,
а також гарантій того, що Україну і надалі підтримуватимуть західні партнери
і вона зможе більше інтегруватися на Захід, ніж за таких ініціатив, як Кримська платформа.
Сюзан Стюарт не виступає проти Кримської платформи.
Вона просто переконана, що це питання нині не таке пріоритетне, як необхідність справжніх, а не косметичних реформ в Україні.
Натомість інший німецький експерт Вільфрід Їльґе підтримує Кримську платформу
і бере активну участь у її просуванні.
Сюзан Стюарт або інші бояться, що це буде тільки привід символічно користуватися зовнішньою політикою,
щоб замовчувати важливі теми у внутрішній політиці.
Якщо це буде тільки символічна пропаганда, тоді я підтримую такий тезис, але я так не думаю.
Чому? Сьогодні ми маємо великі проблеми з правами людини в Криму.
Є великий тиск в українському громадянському суспільстві, щоб більше займатися такими проблемами.
І я не можу уявити, що українське керівництво інвестує зараз так багато зусиль в такий формат тільки для символічних цілей.
Я думаю, це також не проходить в українському внутрішньому дискурсі.
Кримська платформа - можливість підтримати формат постійної координації між Україною
та іншими державами щодо невизнання анексії Криму і моніторингу ситуації у Чорному морі, вважає Вільфрід Їльґе.
За його словами, хоча кримське питання останні кілька років і не замовчувалось,
але ЄС не звертав достатньо уваги на проблему анексії Криму і зростаючих ризиків навколо мілітаризації півострова Росією.
Планується, що у Кримській платформі візьмуть участь майже 40 високопосадовців з різних країн, включно з президентами деяких держав.
Хто представлятиме Німеччину наразі невідомо.
На запит DW у Міністерстві закордонних справ ФРН заявили, що про це повідомлять пізніше,
і водночас запевнили у підтримці Кримської платформи.
Уряд Німеччини не визнає анексію Криму Росією, яка суперечить міжнародному праву,
та підтримує зусилля щодо врегулювання конфлікту.
Тому Федеральний уряд, як і європейські партнери, позитивно ставиться до Кримської платформи.
Німеччина послідовно підтримує територіальну цілісність України,
тому їй також слід приєднатися до Кримської платформи, вважає Сюзан Стюарт.
Однак, за її словами, немає сенсу інвестувати в ініціативу значні дипломатичні чи політичні ресурси,
адже передусім успіхи чи невдачі України у реформах визначать, чи виживе вона як суверенна і демократична держава.
Я не кажу, що Німеччина взагалі не буде вкладати жодних ресурсів в Україну.
Я б так не казала. Німеччина вже вкладає багато ресурсів в Україну.
Тож я маю на увазі те, що такими ініціативами важливо показати, що так, ми й надалі підтримуємо територіальну цілісність та суверенітет України.
Ми віддані цьому. Але знову і знову. Ми постійно зазначаємо, що процеси реформ стоять на першому місці.
Тим більше, що стосується ситуації на Донбасі.
Все залежить від того, як російська сторона поводить себе.
А зважаючи на російську поведінку на Донбасі, а тим більше стосовно Криму, то на даний момент жодні принципові зміни не можливі.
Але процес реформ значно більшою мірою перебуває в руках українського керівництва та української еліти.
Тож усі зусилля мають бути спрямовані саме туди.
Німеччина і Берлін теж були розділені багато років.
Та чи можна проводити паралелі з Кримом?
На думку експертів, не зовсім, бо поділ Німеччини був у часи "холодної війни", і тоді був баланс сил:
Західна Німеччина у НАТО, а Східна - у Варшавському договорі.
Конфлікт же між Україною і Росією - асиметричний.
Водночас варто скористатися політичним досвідом Західної Німеччини,
якій вдалося заручитися підтримкою жителів Східної Німеччини через соціальні проєкти, масмедіа тощо.
Наприклад, у нас була певна програма для територій, які були біля Стіни.
Там були певні соціальні-економічні програми, які також мали ефект на серця й душі тих людей.
Я думаю, це також повинна бути частина Кримської платформи -
що ми можемо з боку України і Європи зробити, щоб не втрачати ментально людей, які зараз живуть в Криму.
Опитані DW експерти переконані, що реформована Україна буде набагато більше спроможною
відстоювати свою територіальну цілісність, ніж країна, де панують олігархічні й корупційні підходи.